es gibt noch ko sieger jedes noch sehr
heiß ich dass ich noch mal bei dieser
bestehen hey leute willkommen zu loch
ness tag einen sicher vergessen zu sagen
dass der adventskalender der
adventskalender sein wird die nicht
auspacken liege auch ein bisschen daran
dass es nicht geplant war von mir das
dass der letzte ist aber es ist jetzt so
passiert und ich habe die zeit genossen
bzw auch genutzt um auf instagram ein
bisschen aktiver zu sein und ich hatte
auch einige kooperation beziehungsweise
habe ich noch und ja deswegen war es
erstmal ein paar tage pause aber heute
heute sinnlose tat leute heute geht es
los ich habe schon eine ärmel
ich habe schon ein ding hier aufgegangen
letztes jahr habe ich locker damit
gestartet dass ich die wohnung aufräumen
das passiert allerdings erst morgen zu
die erklärung der blog ist nicht kennt
ich werde einen tag drehen und den
nächsten tag das video hochladen das
heißt wir nicht morgen sage ist das für
euch auch morgen also diese pflanze hat
ja wirklich nichts mit weihnachten zu
tun
die muss weg sieht aus als ob wir auf
hawaii wäre ich hoffe dieser politik
mich zu sehr auf
aber super kosian ich fühle mich damit
wie ein teddybär
ich weiß nicht genau wo wir waren auf
jeden fall die letztes jahr wie es damit
gestattet dass ich die wohnung
aufgeräumt habe dass mich gesagt und
dann ist morgen dieses jahr startet
locken ist mit dem adventskalender den
ich für timo machen und zwar war ich
heute einkaufen und vor paar tagen ich
wollte es unbedingt vermeiden alles bei
amazon zu bestellen weil ich glaube dass
die lieferanten genug zu tun haben
deswegen habe ich mich in den einkaufs
wahnsinn begeben oder selber eingekauft
bin ein bisschen ausgerastet ich bin
nicht in der preiskategorie geblieben
die ich mir vorgenommen habe ich will
gar nicht wissen was ich jetzt am ende
für diesen adventskalender ausgegeben
habe aber jedes geschenk ist mit liebe
für timo und ich hoffe ihr freut sich
und dann wird sich wahrscheinlich freuen
ich habe mir vorgenommen ihn selber zu
basteln
das wird auch super toll ich habe
richtig bock und als grundlage benutze
ich den aufsteller den ich von robs
chips bekommen habe also küste überhaupt
hat der chips rausgebracht das ist jetzt
keine bezahlte werbung oder sonst was
aber ich hab diesen aufsteller bekommen
wo die ganzen chips drin waren
und hier diese aussteller angeguckt und
dachte mir so irgendwie ist das die
perfekte ganz kalender und deswegen
benutze ich den hier
und dafür müssen wir als allererstes
dieses schwarz und das ganze design weg
machen weil das liegt natürlich nicht
sehr weihnachtlich aus so das ist mein
plan ich halte das jetzt so dahinter und
dann könnte ich einfach ansprüchen ich
habe richtig zufällig rewe bund lag
gefunden es ist mir ein für heimwerker
königin die sich damit auskennen ich
weiß das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich alles
in einem riesen chaos enden
mama das fenster auch das riecht schon
es geht ja es tut mir leid
naja es fliegt strom sowie schnee muss
man sagen
weil ich meinen mundschutz dafür
anziehen ich habe das gefühl dass mir
ein mundschutz dafür ansehen sollte wir
machen das lieber auf dem balkon das ist
quatsch das hierzu noch über das bett
hier oben ist die luft gleich viel
besser
das ist einfach jetzt mal da draußen
trocknen und ich mache zugleich trägt
man bei sowas wirklich mal ein
mundschutz
nicht nur im supermarkt jetzt kommt der
beste teil jetzt kommt für mich der
beste teilen ich habe ganzen sachen
geholt und freue mich darauf diese
wunderschönen tütchen reinzumachen ich
habe sie bei müller entdeckt dachte mir
mensch klasse dann muss ich ja gar nicht
jedes einzelne dinge in geschenkpapier
verpacken so ein beispiel
wir haben hier tolle story in der
packung sondern hat ihre kleinen
ich denke ich dass sie meine analysen
nach eine sache die ich ganz toll fand
ist aber ein bisschen teurer wieder
gewesen 20 euro die kunst künstliche
intelligenz und der sinn des lebens und
kino interessiert sich sehr für
künstliche intelligenz das thema ist
komplett an mir noch vorbeigezogen ich
weiß ja gar nichts von ja ein bisschen
groß ist es dann trotzdem weiter einfach
so hierzu die zahlen sind das alles ist
habe ich alles untereinander nur danach
für die schönsten zahlen die ich jemals
ich bin die so gut die versprühen für
mich so ein weihnachtsgefühl dann geht's
weiter
auch sehr wichtig diese motive sag mir
bitte nicht das bei euch auch so richtig
retro weihnachts gefühle aufkommen
das war so typisch geschenkpapier was
bei uns zu hause war
ich habe kinder überraschung frei auch
kommen bitte passt da rein glaube weil
ich als kind so was nie bekommen hat ist
das jetzt für mich alles also so schön
das überraschungsei geht nichts zu hören
und das passt natürlich dahin was das da
rein
das kann ich niemals verstehen fleisch
jobs aber timo steht da total drauf weil
das ich das nochmal im quark macht wenn
er mal wieder so seine sport phase dann
macht ihr das hier das finde ich mega
cool wie art auf hiphop covers so 365
cavasin ich mir ja cool und timo ist so
ein hip hop prototyp der feierte ich
unterstützt das und das passt dann
natürlich nicht rein kann werden die
zwei plätze
[Musik]
die designs teilweise nichts abgewinnen
so ein highlight dieser länder alle
wiegens tun jetzt leid und das tut mir
leid dass ich euch das jetzt ins gewicht
aber ich fand das einfach witzig und
team uns jetzt kein übermäßiger
fleischesser aber ab und zu so ein
fleischsnack marke auch und deswegen
dachte ich gönne ich ihnen das im
adventskalender mit salami brezeln album
aber ich brauche euch sprechen wollte
ich hoffe ihr denkt an eure menschen
helfen so während des lok downs jetzt
ich meine dieses locken es wird ganz
anders also so anders sind auch mich
aber wir werden halt nicht herausgeben
können
es wird keinen job vom weihnachtsmarkt
geben keine von irgendwelchen
theaterstücken man ist einfach nur zu
hause bei dem ganzen stress und bei den
ganzen kummer und sorgen sie dann wegen
dieser situation hat man sollte das auch
irgendwo ausnutzen sagen guck mal wann
hatte ich dann meine weihnachtszeit ich
nicht auf irgendwelche weihnachtsfeiern
sein musste wo ich nicht auf den
weihnachtsmarkt gehen musste und was
kann ich da dessen machen was mir auch
ein gutes gefühl geben wird und ich habe
zum beispiel gerade ausmalen für mich
entdeckt
wenn wir auf insgesamt reisten ich bin
gerade ein auswahl
ich habe dieses kalenders wird so
kontrovers ich werde nur kommentare
bekommen und mein gott warum machst du
das 1 o mein gott warum benutze die
verpackung oh mein gott vanessa beef
jerky terry aktiv wie entscheidet man
ortes wird so schwer zu entscheiden was
denn in welchen strichen am ende rein
soll
ich weiß auf jeden fall was natürlich
noch mal eins rein kommt dieser 6 weil
das erzähle ich euch jetzt fällt mir zu
alles klar ich habe ihn für das erste
türchen 1 6 geholt weil wir genau
alkohol november gemacht haben bzw
noch machen das war jetzt für uns kein
kalter entzug wie es vielleicht viele
von meinem content vermuten würden jetzt
ist es einfach eine erinnerung an uns
dass alkohol halt etwas besonderes
bleiben sollte das finde ich nur geil
sie mussten wegen deiner rudolf m und
wenn die warm wird dann erscheinen da
noch mehr von diesen modus und
gleichzeitig so schlapp klammern gekauft
dann muss ich sie gar nicht so
umständlich zu binden sondern noch
einfach nicht immer drauf dann kommt
jetzt
roompot rupert undercover das habe ich
bei rewe gefunden da werden ja auch mal
bücher verkauft und das war auch
bestseller platz eins hier steht aber
hier ist günstiger drauf ich hoffe
einfach dass das gut ist also falls sie
das gelesen habt die mode auf dieses
video nicht sehen
das habe ich ihm verboten als sie das
gelesen habt schreibt mir das gerne
meine kosten
habe ich dennoch nur ein türchen 123
gebracht und 16 begrenzt gewesen und 20
190 2023
ja ich kann dieses jahr wieder für
meinen nachbarn genauso viele beutel
übrig ich hab mich schon gefragt aber
ich habe dieses jahr auf jeden fall
wieder den nikolaus spielen weil es an
halloween in unserem haus irgendwann das
gespenst gespielt habe er so lustig wenn
sich dieses jahr jemanden zu denn das
was der nachbar letztes jahr gemacht
hatte nikolov das war ich und dann
begegnen wir uns so nacht mit unserem
typen so in der hand habe zwar gesehen
dass timo sich gerade ein paar davon
geholt hat aber das ist seine
lieblingsmarke das funktioniert ganz gut
jetzt alles das geschenkpapier verpacken
so ritschel es richtig viel mitgenommen
fünf kirchen sind jetzt so übertrieben
neben den anderen jetzt packen wir mal
die geschenke ein
dieses jahr sind ersten jahr wohl kein
ikea sind können da hat oder hatte ich
letztes jahr war ich kann mich gerade
selber daran nicht halten aber ich
glaube ich hatte letztes jahr kein doch
ich hatte ein hatte ich einen care
ich hätte sonst jedes jahr in ikea dort
hatte ich es bestimmt bestimmt und
dieses jahr habe ich es einfach nicht
dran gedacht können uns gerne so
logitech weil das halt und ist und man
sieht er die these stellen und dann
denke ich so richtig gute idee mit dem
wetab wird der mix festen meinung
geschenk warengruppen festreigen sie
doch nicht aus jetzt kommen tricks wie
sie in jeder kennt den trick 17
das ist für mich das weihnachtliche
geräusche war dies an den ersten advent
denke dann freue ich mich schon
irgendwie macht mich auch extrem traurig
dass diese ganze situation irgendwie hat
man glaube ich noch am anfang des jahres
gedacht die hockey bis weihnachten
erledigt so und da will sie fast durch
jetzt geht's ans nummerieren und da
müssen wir uns seit einen pendlern warum
sich nach uns ich muss das machen ihr
könnt nur zuschauen also ich muss mir
einen plan überlegen wie es am besten
ich weiß schon mal was die nummer eins
sein wird
natürlich höre punkte
die nummer eins gegen nummer 2 sollte
schon was cool ist jetzt mit dem betrieb
muss so ein bang geben
ja komm dosen raumspray lasst uns das
buch nehmen
jetzt kommt das buch vw kombi cs5 das
entspricht meiner ästhetik das ist das
perfekte taugen schon die nummer auch
mit einem ganz tollen ganz tollen
partner sticker nummern stehen jetzt
gibt es dr pepper
ganz beliebt das feeling glaube da wird
er sich sehr darüber freuen
ja am 15 weihnachtstag kinder von turin
perfekt gleich brezen kommen die 23
einfach nur bei zu farblich besser passt
also sorry denn just jubelt und die 24
ist dann die na gut das geschafft mein
gott oh mein gott das wird niemals in
dieses ding rein passen was habe ich mir
dabei nur gedacht richtig ich habe nicht
nach
das wird doch vielleicht war richtig gut
stapelt natürlich zeigen moment eine
schnee matte und mein gott mit silber
glitzer am das ist das kleine detail was
noch gebraucht hat ich muss es anders
machen
willkommen bei meinem upcycling bastl
projekt war es funktioniert ok ich will
aber nicht mehr heißen wenn ich nicht
immer einen plan z im ärmel hat jetzt
kommt mein plan fällt willkommen zu
meiner zweiten entscheidung ich stelle
ihn jetzt einfach hier
das im flur das ist schön da fühlt man
sich gleich ganz weihnachtlich hier ist
eh schon weihnachtstag und ich so
halbherzig schon mal drauf gemacht habe
die aber noch nicht ganz so richtig
zählt ich mache musik kamera ein
bisschen gerade ja und das wird jetzt
unser ach so kann ich noch die farb
einstellung ändern
ok
das bild muss auf jeden fall gegenüber
steht seit
[Musik]
die geholt
ich liebe ihn ich liebe ihn ich liebe
ihn ich liebe ihn ich liebe ihn ich
liebe ihn und damit meine ich nicht
klima ich liebe diesen adventskalender
diese umrandung weihnachtliche bilder
und habe mit bildern drin aber so timo
friedrich hafen mein gott da wird nicht
hass und jetzt werden wir seine reaktion
das breit dass sich die welt wie sind
haare gemacht
123 keine vision
warum hast du so schöne nicht bereit
wenn ihr eingefahren
wohnt man sieht schon so weihnachtlich
als ok ich hab' noch nicht gekriegt wenn
man nicht gekühlt ich habe noch nicht
gekühlt
ja okay ich frage mich wozu diese ganze
wand
[Musik]
auch ist morgen leute sagt tschüss gute
nacht mein toller tag toll
adventkalender ich freue mich